all right everybody
i'm uh i'm sort of back i actually don't
know what's going on with the youtube
stream um it's very weird
um i see i'm monitoring on youtube i see
myself i see the chat
so that's good it seems that that at
least is working
um but for whatever reason when i'm
trying to
deal with the settings they just
it takes me to some other offline stream
it's very very weird so i know that
there's people
uh in the chat saying everything's fine
and that's great it's great that it
seems that way but i can assure you
uh that not everything is fine as i try
to get some live video here
of this stream checking whether now this
has live video in the room not yet okay
so we are not yet live in the room yeah
there's something very strange going on
and it's something about the connection
between
restream and youtube that is not working
there do seem to be some elements in the
system i don't even know if i can see
super chats
now people are saying facebook is not
live
well i don't know about that what i'll
do is i'll just shut off facebook and
restart it
it looked like it was live we're working
out all of the kinks
but um yeah not too much i think this is
going to have to
probably be it for now um
my hair is fine yeah people worried
about my hair that's that's no big deal
um let's see
okay well i think that things are good
enough
um facebook is on but out of sync
well just refresh that but we're fully
back on all platforms now and i think
that this is probably as
far as it'll go oh let's see a super
chat came in
i see it in the chat from timmy lunsford
but i'm not seeing it in my control
panel where it tells me where the super
chats came in
i suspect that sam cedar is doing
something very ugly here
in order to uh prevent me from getting
to those
million subscribers i think that that's
very very reasonable let me just refresh
and then we'll see what we've got
but no it does seem as though i'm able
to see super chats
and um things are okay the vegan
villainess
sent a two dollar super chat in order
for me to be able to get a new computer
that's very nice no it it doesn't seem
to be
the the thing is everything i use is
cloud-based like restream is cloud-based
everything is cloud-based so there's
really no reason why
being on this com like the my computer
is
really an afterthought here the only
other thing i can think of
would be settings in streamlabs
obs but again i just i don't
see that there's really any possible
issue there
um but okay it is what it is we are live
and i think that's a great start captain
crunch says we are back
thanks david yes we are back
and oh cnbc stream isn't working
yeah maybe there's a bigger picture here
maybe there's a bigger picture but we're
going to grind it out i do appreciate
everybody over on twitch who is
gleefully
saying that twitch is working completely
and totally fine and that's true
ms paint physics or ms paint physics
has signed up with twitch prime grok23
boy meets mini signed up
uh who else bit 101 and pink and blonde
all of these people over on twitch
why is it that twitch is working audio
only through facebook
now that doesn't make sense how could
that possibly be audio only through
facebook let me check my own facebook
stream
and see what's going on there that's not
even a configuration possibility
let's see what we've got facebook
can you imagine audio only somehow
i guess we would be under posts
live no everything's fine every facebook
is working fine there's video and audio
happening on facebook so that's that's a
beautiful beautiful thing
um thanks to maria bohm who says when is
the deepak
versus stephen kenneth destiny bonnell
the second practice match happening
nothing's scheduled yet
nothing scheduled yet but i i may soon
have things to announce let's see
streaming software issue
stream keys yeah i just don't think that
this is the uh
i don't think this is the issue i think
we've got something more
systemic going on my friends um
crimson elric has subscribed with prime
and says hey david keep it up fellow
bostonian chris evans aka
captain america was on bill maher and
has started a political engagement
website we need to get you on real time
cheers i would be glad to appear anytime
tonk trucks says david you need more
emotes
we have enabled bttv emotes and i am
taking requests for ones that you
believe
should be added you can email me through
my website
and tell me which bttv emotes would you
like to see added
and i will gladly oblige i will gladly
do it for you
um okay let's see what else we've got
oh there are people signing up who i
want to thank carrie lyle
is new member number one today at
joinedpakman.com
eric flowden is new member number two
whoa we're not 122. number two all right
we're getting everything set up
everything everything's okay
and then mary quinn is new member number
three today at joinpakman.com so glad to
see that
that is working um people wanting to
check out the latest on social blade
okay yeah we can do that let me pull
that up
there was a big big weekend
of um drama between me and sam cedar now
as many as
of you know sam sunk to a new low
and went and hosted msnbc in order to
try to get to a million subscribers
before i do so let's see how we're doing
we're still kicked up whoa hold on a
second as you can see here we've got
this
beautiful little spike beautiful little
spike that's going on and now we are at
9 29 on the david pakman show side
and 9 16 on the samuel
cedar side so we are currently at plus
13 and of course if you've missed all of
this drama
you're probably better off but what's
going on is we are both in a
simultaneous race to 1 million youtube
subscribers
and um my goal also
oh by the way the other thing i should
mention is my goal
is to get there by election day let me
see
where the project where are projections
let's see here we go
people wondering why it says midweek
politics it's that used to be the name
of the show
and we just weren't able to change the
youtube channel subscriber milestone
let's see where we are here um
oh hold on we've gotta actually
let me see if i can fix up this shot for
you guys a little bit you can't even see
i apologize we're still getting things
set up there we go
so we are now expected to hit
1 million
on november 30th
we have moved up we have moved up
the the expected 1 million date from
january 9th
into december now into november
30th which is unbelievable so now we're
only 27 days
from the november third date that's
fantastic that's very exciting and let's
not spend any more time on that right
now
because we are standing by here as you
can see for a white house press briefing
we are going to mute out some of these
other feeds let's see if we have audio
we do have audio beautiful okay so
things are going very very well there
all right good um okay we i have a bunch
of different video clips and things for
you to play for you after i was hoping
to play for them before
um play play for those for you before
now the other issue
is that we may be having a little bit of
stream lag it may be that my connection
here
simply cannot keep up with
the settings that i've chosen and i may
have to deal with that
i can't change that live so i'll have to
look at that tomorrow probably i
apologize i'm on a different
internet connection today i'm in a
different place there's a lot of
different things going on so i'm going
to do the best that i can
to have a solid solid stream today
super chats are flying in classy andy
says i read an article from irish
american journalists who say that irish
americans are way more conservative and
trump supporters
than their spiritual homeland what i can
tell you is
very anecdotally that in boston
um irish bostonians probably on balance
are a little more conservative yeah
skitoshi nakayobro says
yo haved i don't know what the heck just
happened but i'm glad you got things
fixed
but gabe oytoucher says on biographics
world your net worth is listed at 5
million
oh my god is this why you constantly
offer deep membership discounts you can
live comfortably off of interest while
operating your business at a loss that's
exactly right gabe that's exactly right
i have so much money that i can offer
what in some states would be illegal
illegal membership discounts and case in
point i'll offer one right now
membership on my website is the number
one source of funding
that coupon code right up there 2020 now
will save you 66 percent off of a
membership
as kaylee is here i will thank everybody
afterwards
hello everyone democrats in congress
failed to act in the best interest of
americans hardest hit
by this pandemic amid inaction president
trump stood up for every american who
through no fault of their own
needed relief politics as usual should
find no place during this pandemic
but democrats rejected multiple clean
bills to provide
relief clean the american people are
tired of games
they seek leadership and president trump
delivered
this weekend president trump took
executive action designed to provide
the relief democrats have denied to
those who need it most
through four executive orders he took
the following step steps
on the payroll tax he deferred payments
of the employee portion of certain
payroll taxes from september 1st
through the end of 2020 on unemployment
assistance states will provide 25
percent cost sharing amounting to a
total of 400
per week and benefits through the end of
the year okay
and then third he extended the eviction
uh
protections um president trump will
direct hud to prevent
evictions resulting from financial
hardships caused
by the virus doing everything in his
executive capacity
to make sure those renting and those
homeowners are protected
finally on student loans he extended
zero percent interest and suspended
loan payments through the end of the
year the bottom line is that these
actions will help americans president
trump is for the american people and
democrats failed to deliver
also earlier this year hundreds of
americans working
men and women at the tennessee valley
authority the tva were told that they
would lose their jobs to lower paid
foreign workers imported from abroad and
then
suffered the further indignity of
training their foreign replacements
president trump boldly and resolutely
intervened in defense of these
hard-working americans
rallying to their case rushing to their
aid and taking action to restore
their jobs he invited laid off workers
and their representatives to the white
house and then he fired the chairman of
the board of the tva and one other board
member
president trump offered an ultimatum the
firings would continue until the cruel
and heartless decision to fire
the hard-working the beatings will
continue until morale improves right
reverse layoffs have been canceled and
tech workers have been rehired
in the words of gay henson president of
the engineering associates ifpte local
1937 the labor union representing the 20
of the 2200
highly skilled professionals employed by
the tva in miss henson's words the
president's personal intervention saved
these jobs restored the workers to their
rightful place
and set tva on the path to returning to
its mission of service to both the
workers
at the tva and to the people of this
country and with that i'll take
questions here we go yes
haley thank you starting right there
with the president's actions over the
weekend
how quickly can americans expect to see
that extra 400 oh she can't get ahead of
the president on that so we hope to see
it quickly
um and close to immediately i don't have
an exact readout for you on time but a
lot of this will depend on states
um and them applying because as you know
it's 75
federal government um covering and 25
the states and they can use cares
funding or even existing unemployment
funds
for that 100 but it will require an
application process and given that part
of it is up to the states in the
application process
is it possible that there will be a
delay in that some individuals won't see
this relief at all
we will be working around the clock to
make sure there's not a delay
but any delay that does exist it's
important to note um where that delay
and the responsibility
won't be trump's fault pelosi and chuck
schumer they were offered a clean
extension not of 400
of unemployment uh benefits trump's
responsible for getting people money any
delays
are everybody else's fault stood up for
the american worker at a time when
democrats refused to do so
just to be very clear you're saying that
you're going to work around the clock
you want it to get to americans quickly
are we talking weeks are we talking a
month can you pinpoint the timeline
i can't join a timeline other than we'll
be working around the clock and we
encourage democrats on the hill
uh to come back secretary mnuchin has
said he's willing to review any proposal
because
the american people deserve better than
the games and the partisanship they've
seen from nancy pelosi chuck schumer and
their democrat
colleagues thanks kaylee two questions
just to follow up on what kristen was
asking is there a mechanism by which the
federal government can provide the 300
immediately even if states don't provide
the one hundred
good well it's important in fact
required by statute that 25
of that money um be provided by states
and the 75 percent is what we can do
from the federal government side i would
note
states can look to cares act funding
as a way to bring that hundred dollars
forward they can also look to the
general fund
but we will be pursuing every creative
way possible to make sure
that the preeminent priority prevails
and that is making sure that this money
gets to america's workers then the
the orders of the president sign that
doesn't address funding for small
businesses
or for schools or stimulus checks the
schools will be open right because they
don't need to find
all of those things and is he willing to
negotiate with democrats
he absolutely would love to see both of
those things school funding is very
important
and he's been for a second round of
direct payments
so we encourage democrats to really
negotiate with us in good faith so far
they have not done so
in fact moving further away from us
rather than towards us negotiations work
by coming towards one another
i mean it's incumbent upon democrats to
do that they say they've come down from
three trillion to two trillion is the
white house willing to go up from one to
something else
they've still put in several
non-starters they've never put forward a
serious proposal in the notion
before they claim to have come down they
actually went up and then they wanted
100 billion in school funding we said
okay we'll give you more than you ask
for 105 billion
to which was no longer acceptable so
they've been fundamentally unserious
with
each and every one of their uh their
offers in this negotiation
right yes thank you a number of
democrats but also
republican senator ben sasse has
suggested these executive actions are
unconstitutional can you
walk us through what the white house is
not just unconstitutional trump said
he's not going to need executive
orders because he's going to get things
done the right way remember that guys
first i would note that what we are
doing is entirely within the executive
capacity
of the president on student loans
section
2a 2 subsection a of the higher
education relief opportunities for
student acts of 2003
which is 20 usc 1098 bb
authorizes the secretary to waive or
modify provisions of student financial
assistance programs to
ensure that individuals who've been
affected by the national emergency are
not worse off financially there's
another statute for that one section 432
of the higher education act of 1916. i
think it's subsection 888 actually
my from my recollection deployment uh
the stafford act 42 usc
5174 says the president after a state
applies for it
can provide assistance to people who
have been adversely affected by
by a major disaster these are often
known as other needs assistance or o
a um on payroll tax authority 26
usc 7508a plainly authorizes the
treasury secretary
to provide any taxpayer that has been
affected by federally declared disaster
with an extension of up to a year this
was used before
uh when the secretary extended the
individual filing deadline
um for 2019 taxes from april to july and
finally
for evictions the authority would be
suggesting that hhs in a hud consider
whatever legal authorities they have to
protect americans
and also the president merely instructed
in that
eo uh that we should do everything
within the lawful capacity of the
executive branch to protect americans
from evictions
yes definitely on china is the
administration planning to respond to
the new
sanctions that china announced this
morning on several lawmakers and other
people in the united states
so i won't get ahead of the president on
any actions
but we are certainly aware of the
announced sanctions and instead of
taking meaningful actions such as
immediately repealing the national
security law
and stopping the system the systematic
repression of uyghurs the chinese
communist party opted to respond with
this symbolic
and ineffectual action and a growing
number of nations around the globe
how did our government become so idiotic
like even the communication between this
administration and the press is just
just a joke meaningless drivel continue
to do so is there any discussion kaylee
are you listing
chinese companies on the u.s stock
exchange again i won't um get ahead of
the president on any official
announcements
thank you the president said over the
weekend that he had heard from democrats
about
uh wanting to restart these negotiations
who exactly did he hear from and then
also his tweet this morning uh regarding
he said that he had his
uh he said that leader uh schumer and
speaker publixie had his number
in regard regarding negotiations uh does
that mean he
is going to play a larger role in this
process going forward or is it still
going to be secretary mnuchin and the
chief of staff
well they speak on the president's
behalf he's been actively engaged in the
negotiations and working closely with
secretary mnuchin and the chief of staff
democrats should come to the table on
their immediate statement
in the aftermath of the president
issuing these eos
says that they would like to meet
halfway but you know those are empty
words from democrats that they'd like to
meet halfway because so far they've just
gone in the other direction
did anybody reach out to him i'm not
going to go through the president's call
because nobody can ask him later like
he'll have a press briefing at about 5
30.
jeff thank you kaley secretary pompeo
has raised the issue of
russia and bounties on u.s soldiers in
afghanistan
with his counterpart does that mean that
the administration now considers the
intelligence on this
secure or clear and if so does the
president plan to raise it with
president yeah so on the part about
secretary pompeo i'd refer you to the
state department that was a new york
times story so
in terms of his personal con
conversations i would refer you there
um but on the part of the president he
this was unverified
not conclusory as the new york times
conclusively reported
um the president will always act in the
interests of our troops and
look no further than the killing of
solomonia and al-baghdadi which
brought vindication to hundreds of u.s
servicemen and women who lost their
lives overseas just to be clear does
that mean that
you did pompeo did not raise this does
that mean that i would refer you to the
state department but are the two sides
seeing this administrating that
intelligence is different here
and the state department again you're
asking me to verify reporting that would
be in the realm of the state department
but
rest assured this president will always
act in the best interests of our yeah
rest assured thanks kailey
back on the executive orders the
president signed this weekend as a
candidate donald trump
criticized fairly sharply uh beautiful
barack obama's use of executive orders
and perfect
faulting him for failing to reach deals
with members of congress
how are the president's actions this
weekend any different from
uh president obama because it's trump
different when you consider the fact
that
president barack obama uh utilized
executive order uh to push forward a
policy
um that he denied he had the right to
push forward 23 times on dapa and on
daca he said
at least 23 times i don't have the power
to do this and then he went on to do
just that oh there is something special
the various legal authorities on the
part of the president and in terms of
deal making
i would note that the cares act was
landmark legislation
you know at the heat at really the
height of this pandemic right obamacare
wasn't landmark
i mean come on guys one week from first
drafting to enactment
um and by comparison if we want to go
back to president obama the american
recovery act during the great recession
took roughly three months from inception
to enactment as law under single party
control
uh this president managed to push the
cares act through divided government a
very big accomplishment on the part of
the president
because it's an acute emergency and no
one in their right mind would say we
don't need to do anything
new drugs in the united states is
apparently on hold now
amid allegations of insider trading is
the president concerned
that his infrastructure here is being
misused that the defense protection
act uh funds are are potentially being
not at all uh misused would he pull the
plug on
the kodak deal and what does it say
about the safeguards that you have in
place
that this potentially could have uh
everything's fine
so first the president will always act
in the best interest of the american
people
as you noted as soon as we became aware
of these allegations the international
development finance corporation
said that the recent allegations of
wrongdoing raise serious concerns
we will not proceed any further unless
these allegations are cleared
uh the president has strong faith in the
process here we've used the dpa more
than 30 times
to increase production one phrase to
listen for with kaylie is
i would also note that anytime she goes
i would also note that it's like a
distraction gaslighting trigger word
the number of ventilators on hand at 69
000 and we'll have more than
10 000 10 000 more by the fall so this
president
has used the dpa effectively but we're
certainly aware of the kodak
allegations and take them seriously
would he pull the plugs on that deal
i'll leave that to the president but he
takes these very seriously we all
speculate as to what that investigation
finds thank you
two questions for me um the president
just tweeted that gettysburg would be
one of the two sites he's looking at
what can you characterize the message
that he'd want to be sending with
that choice if it was that choice yeah i
won't get ahead of the president as to
what his convention speech will look
like
but the president has done a lot to
bring this
oh i didn't know that pausing by the way
some people i didn't know that trump
i checked out of the weekend that trump
was no longer looking at the white house
law and that's interesting
country together we've faced
unprecedented challenges and
uh he's worked to make sure that the
american people are
are best equipped and taken care of to
rise above the challenges that we face
and he has a strong record of
achievement that he'll be touting on
that day
sorry there'd be another question uh is
there a message to the protesters in
belarus
is is president looking at that trump
has no idea where that country even is
yes so um we are looking at that and
we're deeply concerned by
we're looking very very closely at
having donald trump uh uh
taught where on the map belarus is and
then once we get to that
he may have a statement in a few weeks
belarus presidential election
severe restrictions on ballot access for
candidates prohibition of local and
dependent observers at polling stations
intimidation of opposition candidates in
the detention of peaceful protesters
and journalists have marred the process
and we urge the belarusian government to
respect the right of peace
to peaceably assemble and to refrain uh
from use of force
yes thanks bailey um is the president
willing to
uh provide some aid for states and local
governments giving that
given that the administration's asking
states to pay for a quarter of the
national guard assistance and now
order of the unemployment benefits yeah
the president's always been clear here
that you know he
wants to support state and local
governments but only for covet-related
matters and he doesn't want to bail out
blue states that had structural problems
long before this so that's where
his priorities lie yes i have two
questions one from somebody who
can't be here today but first of all the
president also just tweeted
student athletes have been working too
hard for their season to be cancelled so
does he
disagree with college's counseling
sports and how would he guarantee their
safety a lot of loose strings on this
guy's mask right
if games did go ahead yes i spoke to the
president of the oval office about that
just before walking out here and he is
very much would like to see college
football
safely resume their sport and as he
mentioned in that tweet
a lot of these college athletes you know
work their whole lives to get
you know four years um sometimes they're
redshirted an extra year if they're
lucky
they work their whole lives for this
moment and he'd like to see them have a
chance to live out their dreams
a question from anthony leaker the
chronicle fashion guide
do you have any reaction to the
resignation of the prime minister and
cabinet in
lebanon yeah the president's aware of
the situation but that was just breaking
as i came out so i have nothing to add
no comment other than our heart is with
the people and those who lost their
lives
christian thanks kailey two on the
orders um is the administration
at all concerned that funding the
federal government's cost share through
fema
could leave the government underfunded
for
hurricane season um and then secondly on
the housing provisions are we expecting
this president has shown himself to be
committed
to fully respond to every hurricane like
that one in puerto rico
i'm just curious why did the president
extend the addiction moratorium
as it was outlining cares is that
because it was deemed unconstitutional
so on evictions so on evictions i would
note that the president took
four strong actions here and again the
eviction moratorium
created there is a temporary moratorium
put in place by the cares act so the
president
did what he can within his executive
capacity and it was four part taking all
lawful measures to prevent residential
evictions
number two instructing hhs and cdc uh
to measure to take measures to
temporarily prohibit residential
evictions
um on hud prioritizing federal fundings
that can be used
as financial assistance to struggling
renters and homeowners and also hud
working with its grantees and partners
to ensure that homeowners are not forced
out and with regard to hhs
as they explore their executive
authority here
42 usc 264-a author authorizes the
surgeon general in consultation with the
secretary
to enforce such regulations as is in his
judgment
that are necessary to prevent the
introduction transmission or spread of
communica
communicable diseases so it will be
within hhs
purview to determine whether covid meets
those standards and it could go a long
way in helping americans
who face eviction and your second
question it was about fema
is there a concern that you know pulling
from the disaster funds could leave them
unprepared for
the rest no no no no really the worst
part it's gonna be fine
yeah so there is that snapback provision
that if um
fema does get below a certain level that
that money will snap back so that is
certainly a concern and we'll make sure
that two things happen that americans
get paid but also that there's enough
funding there
to safely go through hurricane season
thank you thank you very much two
questions
what do you like the white house would
like to see happening in lebanon right
now
next and this weekend the u.s reached 5
million
coronavirus cases in brazil 100 000
deaths
as healthcare expects compares the
response from
both government what went wrong here and
there
um so first with lebanon that was your
first question you know we're monitoring
the situation closely as i've said our
heart goes out to the men and women who
lost their lives
it's an absolute tragedy um and the
president participated in a virtual
conference with international leaders
to work closely in our international
response effort we are delivering
aid to the region and our deepest
condolences go out to the victims
um with regard to the u.s response to
the coronavirus we've done more testing
than any country in the world
nothing went wrong here what do you this
has been the best response guys come on
um and we do identify more cases we do
have
after all the most too much testing the
president has noted so many tests
when you look at the us response the
therapeutics beginning of this
there was no coronavirus test it was a
novel virus but we
right but that okay so that's important
they keep saying
the u.s was in the situation where this
was a new virus to the u.s
no we didn't have a test this was a new
virus everywhere nobody had a test
and yet other countries still figured it
out immediately worked to get more than
a hundred emergency use authorizations
to identify
uh various types of testing on
therapeutics there was
no therapeutic that we knew to work with
cove but it was a novel virus this was
the case everything
worked and there are more than 200
that's the case everywhere and our
deaths per capita are ninth highest ten
clinical trials on therapeutics and we
have dexamethasone and convalescent
plasma
and others and the vaccine to be on pace
to be uh
completed by the end of the year when
ebola it took four years to go to
completion
uh this president um remember this is a
different type of vaccine but more
importantly it has nothing to do with
trump
securing a vaccine at the fastest rate
ever for a novel pathogen so
this president has a a really historic
coronavirus relief response that we're
happy to talk about comparison
between brazilian daylight um so
going back to his question on hhs and
executive order is there no real
solution then for people who may be
facing eviction
by the end of this month or early
september well there is a solution i've
mentioned the four things that we've
done
um and will continue to do read those
again
the holistic solution rests with
congress and nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer coming to the table
this president instructed his
administration to find every single way
possible that without congressional
democrats who have been unrelenting
uh and lacking in any sort of care or
empathy for the american people at least
when it comes to their negotiating
tactics if they're not going to act and
care for the american people he would so
he instructed this administration to
pursue everything when i see trump i see
caring
caring for people he doesn't know yeah
yeah legal avenue available to us
without chuck and nancy
um and he's done just that
uh-oh thanks is this the last question
before a scripted walk-off
so that with the president bypassing
democrat stalling
with stimulus bill as we've been
discussing this room
um how pressing is it to actually have a
next phase bill because it seems
that the executive order in the three
memorandum that he just signed
really was kind of a wish list of items
he wanted to pass so
how motivated is the white house to push
for a next-based stimulus bill in spite
of what minutes
can you think of a dumber question like
she doesn't even understand her question
yeah the white house is still motivated
you know the president would love to see
the direct payments to americans the
president would love to see
the school funding there are several
items that we'd like to see happen
um the more relief for the american
people and those in need in particular
the better
but this president you know has taken
action to alleviate alleviate
some of that burden but make no mistake
there's still much more that we'd like
to accomplish but that includes
having willing negotiating partners in
congress and so far
we have none on the in the democrat
party it seems
um and then finally one thing i want to
leave you guys with is that 18 days ago
it was last year ted wheeler tweeted
what i saw last night
so this is the unrelated to anything
anybody asked about
scripted walk-off and portland was
powerful in many ways i listened
heard and stood with protesters and i
saw what it means when the federal
government
unleashes paramilitary forces against
its own people
he in fact called our federal agents
paramilitary forces
and around this same time our federal
officers were facing
rioters barricading officers inside the
courthouse trapping officers inside
launching of commercial grade fireworks
a federal agent's hand was impaled by
planted nails
three officers were likely uh were at
least temporarily i should say
um blinded when a laser uh was put in
their eyes this has been an ongoing
tactic by the rioters
um that was 18 days ago i would like to
see when this happens the reporters get
up and leave
but that's more disrespectful to to the
to the office rather than to kaylie and
i don't think they would ever do it
mayor wheeler
stood with the rioters um and against
the quote paramilitary
forces but just four days ago it appears
mayor wheeler had a change of heart
as uh local officers took over the
situation in portland and he
now i guess this is what he believes now
quote when you commit
arson with an accelerant in an attempt
to burn down a building that is occupied
occupied by people who you have
intentionally trapped inside you are not
demonstrating
you are attempting to commit murder uh
he could not be more right about that it
is a drastic change it took him 73 days
i i suppose to come up with that
realization
and what we're seeing in portland with
six nights in a row
riots being declared on wednesday
you had some of these rioters shining
lasers and officers eyes disabled
security cameras broke windows use
boards to barricade the doors and start
a fire with 20 sworn
officers and civilian employees inside
this is unacceptable and it
is encouraging to see that the liberal
mayor of portland finally seems to
realize that
thank you everyone what an idiotic press
briefing
i mean what a completely idiotic press
briefing can you can you i mean it's
just
it's unconscionably dumb um
if you are heading out please do make
sure that you hit the subscribe button
on youtube we're in a race to a million
and if just a couple hundred of you hit
that subscribe button we will instantly
get to 930
000 so if you're done i do have other
things to talk about and i'm going to
play them for you
if you are heading out please hit that
subscribe button on youtube
looking to get to a million and make
sure to follow on twitch where we are
targeting 50 000 followers
um i did want to play for you oh a
couple things i wanted to show you
uh number one um i tweeted
earlier this is a beautiful tweet
arguably my most liked tweet ever
isn't it weird how a coronavirus death
rate of one percent
is plenty low to open everything but
meanwhile voter fraud incidence of
point giga01 means
end vote by mail and a lot of
powerful people retweeting this
including
hugh laurie dr gregory house who i grew
up watching very very powerful tweet
i'm half kidding but anyway check that
out if that's interesting to you what i
did want to play for you is over the
weekend trump had press briefings at his
bedminster golf club
and he did something crazy hold on let
me get this set up
oh there's an ad oh my god what is this
um over the weekend trump did these
bedminster golf club uh
press briefings and he actually lined
him up with his supporters so like the
supporters would boo the media and would
cheer trump during a press briefing
but listen to what trump said here this
is interesting over the next two weeks
i'll be pursuing a major executive order
requiring
health insurance companies to cover all
pre-existing conditions
wait a second you need an executive
order for that obamacare already does
that that's weird
for all customers that's a big thing
i've always been very strongly in favor
we have to cover pre-existing conditions
so we will be pursuing a major
executive order wait a second breaking
news
10 years ago uh obamacare did
well hold on a second how am i so low in
the shot all of a sudden that's really
weird
let me adjust that if you guys don't
mind there we go
i'm still working out the kinks of this
other streaming setup there we go that's
better
my head was cut off um yeah this is the
law
and this is actually a strategy donald
trump now for a while has been trying to
take credit for veterans choice i don't
know if you guys know about veterans
choice
that's an obama-era policy from 2014
and he's just throwing anything he can
at the wall
um to see what sticks quite frankly let
me say
thank you to derrick pippen derek is new
member number four today at
joinpacman.com
uh amber ortego is new member number
five manuel
mendes is new member number six
kirsty landeck is new member number
seven
chileth yee wins
okay is new member number eight i hope i
got that correct
also want to say say thank you to rude
van windgarden who is new member number
nine
and carrie lyle i was already able to
thank so here's the deal i i do
i'm in a different streaming setup for
the rest of the week
i hope to be back for the 5 30 trump
press briefing i actually do need some
help
from somebody who knows about this stuff
so here's the issue i'm having i'm using
restream to stream to multiple platforms
for whatever reason in youtube
when i try to look at the settings for
this stream
it takes me to a private stream called
david pakman show live stream
rather than this actual stream the title
is you know kaylee mcinanny whatever
so i'm going to email my youtube rep and
see if he can get me some help with this
but i need to um
if anybody can help me figure this out i
would very much appreciate it i'll plan
to be back with you guys in just a few
hours